>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Fenella France: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I just want to welcome
you to today's Topics
in Preservation series.
I'm the chief-- name
would be helpful.
Fenella France, chief
of the Preservation,
Research, and Testing Division.
And we're delighted today-- have
today here, Dr. Andrew Davis,
who is one of our chemists here
in the Preservation, Research,
and Testing Division, talking
about Centuries of Cellulose:
Lessons Learned from the
Molecular Analysis of Cellulose
in Aged Paper Collections.
And Andrew has become
a very critical part
of our preservation team,
and we're really delighted.
So Andrew has a background, his
Ph.D. was in polymer science
and engineering from
the University
of Massachusetts,
Amherst in 2014.
From there, he worked at 3M
developing adhesive chemistry
and photographic processes and
came to the library in 2016.
And without further ado, I
will pass over to Andrew.
[ Applause ]
>> Andrew Davis: Great.
Thanks, Fenella.
So I will be talking today
a little bit about cellulose
and paper materials as they age.
And so what I mean by aging--
I'll jump right into it--
is, as far as we're
concerned here,
that means paper durability
and paper permanence.
How does paper behave
and stay preserved
over a long period of time?
And when we're looking
at it as preservationists
and conservators, a lot of times
we can judge it based on what I
like to call the "eyeball test."
Most of the time, you can look
at an object, you can look
at some paper, and say
what is bad, what is good.
Is this in bad shape?
Do we need to do something with
this object, with this material?
But that doesn't
always pass muster.
Sometimes you need
quantitative measurements.
And there are a number
of ways over the years
that people have taken
quantitative assessments
of paper-based materials.
These range from chemical
assessments, like pH
or inductively coupled plasma,
or XRF, which are familiar
to various folks in this room
for analyzing elemental
compositions
or metallic components that
are in paper materials.
There's spot testing.
Again, identifying
specific elemental
or chemical components in paper.
When the eyeball
test doesn't work
or you need something
a little more specific,
you can do optical testing
and then you can also
do physical testing,
things like fold or
tensile measurements
that give you a quantitative
assessment of material.
But what none of these
techniques address is the
underlying fundamental
building block
of paper itself, and
that's cellulose.
And if anyone in here remembers
and really fantastic "Powers
of Ten" video where
it zooms in and out
of different length
scale scales.
You can see what
materials or at what scales.
Cellulose really is the
fundamental building block,
about as small as you
can get, when you start
from the raw materials,
starting from it trees
or wood-based materials
or rag-based materials,
all the way down past
the cellular structure,
past cell walls, past fibrils,
past fibers, down to cellulose.
And what cellulose
looks like is a string
of sugar molecules
linked together--
that's what this N represents--
over and over and
over and over again,
to make a very long
chain polymer.
And there's actually even more
complicated structure there,
where you have hydrogen
bonding, interacting both
within a cellulose chain and
between cellulose chains.
But it really is the fundamental
building material building block
that makes up paper.
And when we talk about
cellulose degradation,
mostly what we're talking
about is cellulose
significant scission
or breakage of cellulose chains.
And the two main mechanisms
that this can happen by--
and if you hold with
me for just this slide,
this is about as deep into the
organic chemistry as I get.
[laughter] You've got acid
hydrolysis where you can break,
usually that oxygen
linkage there,
and you'll take one long
polymer chain of cellulose
and you'll split that up
into two smaller ones.
You can also have oxidation,
where the rings often
will open up.
And then these will expose some
functional groups that can go
on to perform additional
chemistry often
in a degradative nature,
either color changes or again,
chain scissions, and start
breaking down the chains.
And so when you talk
about quantifying this,
how do you quantify
what's happening
to the cellulose molecules
that make up paper?
There's a method that's very
popular in polymer science,
and that's called size
exclusion chromatography.
And like any chromatography,
it separates chemical components
based on some criteria.
And in this case, it
separates polymeric molecules,
large scale molecules,
based on their size.
And it does this by taking
some samples with both large
and small chain cellulose, flows
them through a porous media
that physically separates
them by size,
and so the larger molecules will
come out at a different time
than the smaller molecules.
You can detect them
and then come
up with a quantitative
measurement
of how much small chain
cellulose there is relative
to large chain cellulose that
you started with in your sample.
And we refer to this entire
series as the distribution.
What's the distribution of
cellulose sizes in your sample?
And so I'll refer to
this as the distribution.
And that distribution
can be captured
by a single quantitative
simplification called the
molecular weight.
And I can spend an
entire day talking
about how you make that's
simplistic quantification.
There are different measurements
and points along this
distribution you can use.
But the idea is it's
one simple identifier
for what this distribution
looks like.
You may be more familiar
with that-- whoops--
in terms of the degree
of polymerization.
And that's just another
way of referring
to the molecular weight.
And so if I say "molecular
weight," or if I say "degree
of polymerization," degree of
polymerization just adjusts
for the size of those
sugar repeat units.
But know that I mean
the same thing.
And so if you're more
comfortable thinking about one
or the other, you can
swap those in your mind.
They are both a simplification
of that more complicated
distribution.
And I'll be showing
you examples of both.
I'm not going to get too
deep into preparing samples
for size exclusion
chromatography.
I will say that we are using
a direct dissolution method.
We're taking the cellulose,
we're not doing any
chemical modifications
to it from the paper.
We are directly dissolving
it in a solvent system.
And so for using solvents in
size exclusion chromatography,
that's been used for
decades in polymer science
with synthetic polymers and
plastics, like styrene or PET.
But for cellulose, it's
really just been pinned
down in the last decade
or so how to do this
through a direct
dissolution method.
And that's because it's a
tremendously complicated solvent
and solute system.
Ann Chapatist [phonetic
spelling] has done some
excellent work reviewing
what goes
into these different
systems that you can use
to dissolve cellulose.
And so if you want to know more,
I highly recommend
looking up her work.
But it does take a long time and
it's fraught with complications.
But it can be done, and the
method we're using is one
of the benchmark methods that is
used with cellulose scientists.
It's something we use just
because it's comparative
to other cellulose
researchers in the field.
And so why size exclusion
chromatography?
Like I said, it's a
direct measurement
of the fundamental building
block in your paper materials.
And it's a cornerstone of
polymer science that the size
of a polymer is directly
related to material degradation.
As the material degrades,
the polymer chains
will start breaking.
You can measure that.
As the chains start breaking,
that's intimately related
to material properties; how
strong it is, how durable it is.
It also reveals minor changes
that are perhaps undetectable
or only very subtly detectable
by physical measurements.
And to give you an example
of that, I'll use something
that we use in the lab--
that we've used size exclusion
chromatography in the lab for,
a pretty big team effort that's
been ongoing for a number
of years before I
came here even,
on iron gall ink
treatments, and this is both
in preservation research
and with conservation.
A number of folks I can see
in the room who've been
working on this project.
An iron gall ink is a corrosive,
but historically important ink.
And you can see iron gall ink
induced degradation on objects
from the library collection, as
well as on lab prepared samples
from lab prepared iron gall ink.
And you can see how
corrosive it is.
This is an aged paper
on the right there.
And you can see that
the paper tends to break
and fracture right
along ink lines.
We know this.
We know this is a problem.
But to me, it seemed like size
exclusion chromatography would
be interesting to see
what has happening
to the cellulose molecules in
the area that has been inked.
That's just a little
bit of the chemistry
of how iron undergoes
Fenton reactions.
Both of the bad actors
I talked about before,
acid and oxidative
species, are involved
with a redox reaction of iron.
So really there's a perfect
storm in iron gall ink
for cellulose degradation.
And what I want to see is
whether we can track any changes
of treatments that this team
has been working on developing
to see what's going on at the
molecular level of cellulose.
And so this is that
lab prepared sample
with lab prepared iron gall ink,
and these are two control
samples, starting with unaged,
so just right after inking.
And you can see this is the
molecular weight distribution
from size exclusion
chromatography.
And you can see that there's
high molecular weight species,
up to about a million
grams per mol,
is the predominant size
of cellulose there.
And you have some smaller
components, as well.
And this is just in that
heavily inked region,
the underlying paper.
And it gives you a
degree of polymerization
of about 2800 of the cellulose.
After artificial aging, so this
is high heat, high humidity,
in an oven for 28 days,
you can see that all
of those high molecular
weight cellulose molecules are
almost gone.
There's very little left.
They've all broken down into
much smaller cellulose chains,
about 10,000 molecular weight.
Degree of polymerization reduced
about ten-fold, about 150.
And so these are papers
without any treatment on them.
And the question
is, what are some
of the conservation
treatments we could apply?
What do they do over time?
How do they help preserve,
if they help preserve,
the cellulose and
molecular structure.
And so I'm not going to get
too deep into the details here.
This is something we're hoping
to publish and get out there,
and I don't want to give away
the punchline to any of this.
So I'll talk just very broadly
about different treatments.
And so, for example, all
the treatments I'll show are
after aging.
And I'm going to compare
them to these two controls.
So all of these have
been aged in an oven
after the treatments
have been applied.
And you can see this
first treatment
in red really doesn't seem
to do much of anything.
And size exclusion
chromatography can tell
you that.
You can see both the degree of
polymerization is about the same
and the distribution
shape itself,
the size of all the molecules in
that sample, are about the same.
They look almost
identical to that condition
without any treatment at all.
And if you look at two
additional treatments, again,
both after aging, but these
start to look much more
like pristine samples.
And so by eye, it might be
hard to distinguish these two.
They both look about the same
in the paper material itself
after aging, but these
distributions and this degree
of polymerization
measurement shows you that one
of them is actually slightly
and subtly better
than the other one.
It helps preserve these high
molecular weight components
in the cellulose.
You still have these million
molecular weight species
that match up to
if you had unaged.
So we can stick it in an
oven, apply heat and humidity,
and we know that this treatment
is perhaps better than this one.
And we're trying to dig a little
bit into why that might be.
But that's just an example to
start getting you thinking,
maybe perhaps get
used to looking
at what this data
might look like.
And if you noticed on that Y
size exclusion chromatography
slide I showed, I talked
about micro-sampling.
And a couple of the popular
methods that I talked
about for quantifying
paper condition take
up a lot of paper.
And so that's a scale
schematic representation
of an 8 1/2 by 11
piece of paper.
And to do a physical condition
test, a fold endurance test,
example, needs about
half of an 8 1/2 by 11.
Similarly, a pH extraction needs
about the same amount
of material.
And so it's fine on
lab scale papers,
but if this is something
you want to do
to a collections object,
that's just not acceptable.
Size exclusion chromatography
can use dozens
of micrograms of
material, right?
So this is a cute little
paper biopsy machine.
It's just a kind of tiny hole
punch that punches out samples
that are about one
millimeter in diameter.
And those can perhaps be taken
from collections objects,
from blank pages in a back
of a book, from detritus
that has been shorn off of
a very fragile material,
and that's perhaps a
little more acceptable.
And so the question is,
how can we apply this
to actual collections
items or perhaps books?
And so I wanted to start using
this on a collection of books,
and the books that
immediately came
to mind were the
Barrow Collection.
And William Barrow may be
a familiar name to some
of the folks in this room.
He was a paper chemist, did a
lot of work in the 50s and 60s
on naturally aged paper
chemistry and what's going on.
And here, William Barrow is
working on a fold tester.
There's Cindy Ryan from our
research group doing her best
William Barrow impression.
And if you haven't seen a fold
tester, I'm a big fan of them.
They're very visceral machines.
You get a real sense
of what's going
on what a fold tester
is operating.
And what William Barrow was
trying to do was he was trying
to connect physical properties
to chemical properties
in naturally aged books.
So taking a naturally
aged collection
and seeing how you can connect
the chemical components in paper
to the physical condition
of the durability
and brittleness of that paper.
So I'm going to take a bit of
a detour now, and I'm going
to step away from all of
the technical science stuff
and give you a little
bit of history
about William Barrow
and the Barrow Labs.
Like I said, some
folks may be familiar
with him, some folks may not.
And it's kind of an
interesting story.
And so Barrow often times
gets a lot of credit
for being the originator
of research on pH
and alum-rosin sizing
and its effect
on naturally aged materials.
But it built on a lot of work
that had already been
going on in the field.
Kohler and Hall in Sweden
in the 20s had done perhaps
the first definitive connection
between acidity and
paper deterioration.
There was then a lot
of work done in the 30s
at the National Bureau
of Standards,
at the Government
Printing Office,
in the National Archives,
looking into the fundamental
science of paper degradation,
looking at whether fiber
processing is more influential
than the fiber source, whether
ground wood papers have a
different effect on paper
longevity than rag papers,
on whether sizing and the
acidity that's inherent
in sizing effects
paper degradation.
William Barrow was a book binder
and a craftsman before
he started looking
into the chemistry of materials.
And he started looking into
the chemistry of materials
and he started working
with these researchers
in the National Bureau
of Standards
in the National Archives,
learning chemistry
from them at that time.
And that kind of sparked his
interests from just book binding
to the more fundamental
chemistry of paper conservation.
And it led to his interests
spanning that type of chemistry,
ranging from cellulose acetate
lamination, to deacidification,
to aging of book papers,
both artificial and natural,
to the manufacturing
of durable papers.
And I'm not going to
talk too much about it,
but it's impossible to
talk about William Barrow
without talking about
cellulose acetate lamination.
And so he spent a lot of
time developing, refining,
and pitching the idea of
cellulose acetate lamination
as he learned alongside
these researchers at NBS
and the National Archives.
And this was during the
1930s, took a lot of input
from Bourden Scribner, who was
the chief of the paper section
at the National Bureau
of Standards,
worked with Arthur Kimberly,
chief of the Division of Repair
and Preservation at the
National Archives at the time.
It involved development of
visits to the National Archives,
prototyping with the Mariners'
Museum in Portsmouth, Virginia.
And he came up with this method
for cellulose acetate
lamination, patented,
oddly enough, with all of that
collaboration with just his name
on the patent in 1941.
And that's really where
Barrow got his claim to fame.
And after that, he received
a grant from the Council
on Library Resources to do
studies on paper and book aging
in Richmond, Virginia
at his labs,
and this was in the
1950s and 60s.
And William Barrow
said about this,
perhaps in a quote illustrative
of the work he was undertaking
there, "The task of the ester is
to find, among the
hundreds of possible tests
of the characteristics
of a material,
those which are really
meaningful, i.e.,
those which can be
shown to correlate
with actual experience in use."
And so to undertake
this research,
he collected a thousand books.
These were a thousand
actual books spanning
about 400 years of print dates.
So about 400 years of natural
aging in this book collection.
All sorts of different
compositions, whether they came
from wood pulps, whether
they came from rag fibers,
different geographies,
mostly from western Europe,
a lot from the United
States, but obviously
that included different
climates, as well.
And his goal was to start
doing tests on these books
and to correlate, like I
said, physical properties
with chemical properties.
And the initial tests were
on about 500 books spanning
the range from 1800 to 1900.
Those eventually ballooned
out by another 500 books,
going all the way back to 1500.
And those included physical
tests of, you know, strength
and durability, by fold
testing, like I showed you,
and tear testing, which is
exactly what it sounds like.
Chemical tests started
off with acidity
and rosin testing expanded
out to looking at alum content
and metal carbonate content
and fiber analysis, as well.
What type of fibers
were in there?
How large the fiber size was.
And these are pictures,
not quite as fun
as the animated pictures.
But from the written reports
from William Barrow, 1950s,
showing the equipment
he was using.
And if you look through these
reports from the 1950s and 60s,
actually what I find a little
bit more fun is they are very
1950s in their presentation.
He is showing some of the
researchers from the lab here.
It wasn't just William
Barrow, for example.
Here is Mrs. Virginia Roberson,
both technician and secretary,
putting samples in
an aging oven.
Mrs. Patricia Turner
working on the fold tester.
Mrs. Emily Parr taking
pH measurements.
So these are very much of the
time, but kind of fun pictures
that are shown in
the Barrow reports.
Shows you how many people
are working in the lab here.
And the lab from William Barrow
produced pages and pages of data
about pages and pages of books.
And after he collected
all these data,
he started making correlations.
So for example, year
of manufacture,
checking the tear strength.
How does tear strength in
naturally aged books change
over time with printing?
How does pH and acidity
and chemical content change
over time with printing?
And then how do you
correlate those?
That's down at the bottom there.
Some of the correlations between
alum content and acidity and how
that interfaces with age
of production of the books.
And so the conclusions of
the Barrow Lab came out
and they were summarized.
You know, the effects of
acidity, the effects of alum,
the effects of fiber type.
High acidity, low
pH tends to lead
to poor physical conditions.
The presence of alum is
usually a bad indicator,
unless it's present
alongside calcium carbonate.
Fiber type, wood pulp
type papers tend to be
in worse conditions
than rag type papers.
The mid-1800s onwards showed
to be particularly problematic.
It was, again, the
perfect storm of all
of these components
coming together.
And those ended up being in--
interpreted by Barrow's
suggestions
on paper manufacture, what can
be done to make more durable,
more permanent papers,
as well as work
on comparing artificial aging
and rigorously controlled
natural aging studies.
And really, it was never
explicitly concluded by Barrow,
but the conclusion here is
those results really, right,
are not new conclusions.
The work that was done by the
National Bureau of Standards,
by the National Archives
in the 20s and 30s new
that acidity was bad, knew
that alum-rosin sizing was bad.
But what this proved was
that those results held
in actual naturally
aged book collections.
Not just any naturally
aged book collection,
a really ambitious naturally
a rather ungainly naturally
aged book collection.
So the fact that you could
take those conclusions
from test papers at NBS or
government printing office
and say, we collected a
thousand books from all over,
all sorts of ages, all
sorts of compositions,
and these results hold,
is rather impressive.
There were lots of
conclusions about Barrow's work.
He is often interpreted as the
originator of results on pH
and alum-rosin and wood content.
For example, Rutherford Rogers,
who was the University librarian
at Yale, 1985, was talking
about Barrow and said,
"Barrow startled the library
world with his results."
Right? So it's not--
it's not uncommon
to see Barrow interpreted as
the originator of these results,
even those some results
came before him.
And his lab is not entirely
innocent in this perception.
If you look at the citation
records in these reports,
starting with the very first
one in 1959, about a third
of them had in their
technical citations,
work from the National
Bureau of Standards,
work from the National Archives.
By the last report in 1967,
most of them had disappeared,
less than 1 in 20 were
from those sources.
They were mostly self-citations
of the Barrow Lab.
And so some other folks
have become critical
of that assessment.
Nicholson Baker, who is
perhaps a little bit infamous
for his critique on library
sciences, the total extreme
of the criticism here,
really questioning why Barrow
did any invasive testing
to begin with.
He said, "If Barrow
hadn't chosen to destroy
yet another page in order
to perform his parlor trick,
the recipe for chicken a la
Terrapin would very likely be
with us today."
[ Laughter ]
So you can find both assessments
in the scholarly literature
about William Barrow, that
he really had this large
influential role to
play in paper science,
and that he was just
duplicating others' efforts.
And so I would say that
my personal opinion
of William Barrow is a little
more sympathetic with that
of Barbara Higginbotham
and Sally Cruz Roggia.
And a lot of this history
comes from Sally Cruz Roggia.
She did some excellent work.
I highly recommend
looking up her deep dive
into William Barrow's history.
Saying that, at the time that
that original research was done
in the 20s and 30s, librarian--
conservation minded librarians
at the time were more
interested in durability
and in-use durability,
in taking a page
and making sure it's not
breaking while users are
interacting with the books.
And so the reports from the
National Bureau of Standards,
from the Government Printing
Office, were highly technical,
highly constrained
to the government.
Didn't make their way
much to librarians
that did a lot of work.
For example, here's at the
Enoch Pratt Free Library,
just doing mending and
working to make sure
that the books could be used and
were in good condition for use.
And Barbara Higginbotham
and both Sally Cruz
Roggia make the argument
that Barrow is the
great promoter here.
He's the one that takes
these results and perhaps
by using a collection of a
thousand actual books from all
over the place, a little
more representative
of what is actually
in libraries.
It's something that
can be, you know,
connected with on
a visceral level.
And so while he may not have
done exactly the original
research, his results
were widely influential
for a good number of reasons.
And so after William Barrow's
work, the books found their way
to the library here
in Preservation Research
and Testing.
And the value of these
books now is entirely
in their scientific content.
They have been destructively
tested.
There are very few books,
going back to the 1500s,
that have had pages
ripped out of them
for tear testing
and fold testing.
And the fact that we can still
do this adds tremendous value
to that collection.
And so those were donated
to the library in the 1970s.
They've since been rehoused,
sorted, and barcoded.
Now they're in PRTD Center
for the Library Analytical
Scientific Samples.
They serve as kind of a small
scale museum of book art.
You can take them apart,
look at what's going
on with different books
over different times.
But they do provide another
opportunity for research.
There's been progress
in material science.
in polymer science.
Polymer science was
barely a field
when Barrow started his work.
There's been improvement
in analytical
and instrumental
methods since the 1950s.
For example, size
exclusion chromatography.
And as a study of natural
aging, it's kind of interesting
that there's been
another 50 years of aging.
And we'll go back to
Rutherford Rogers,
that librarian from
Yale University.
We'll finish out his quote that
I gave you a taste of before.
"Barrow startled the library
world with his research results,
which suggested that only three
percent of the papers published
between 1900 and 1949
could be expected to last
for more than 50 years."
William Wilson at the
National Bureau of Standards,
around the year 2000, could
do the math, and said,
"It's almost the end of
the century and somehow,
most of those books
haven't known
that they were supposed
to disappear."
[laughter] So some
of the conclusions
from that data obviously
need revisiting.
And so one of the
tremendous efforts
that have been undertaken in
PRTD is digitizing those pages
and pages and pages of data.
So there are a thousand books.
There's about 16-ish
data points each.
I say "-ish," some books are
missing a couple of data points.
So that gives you
16,000 data points.
And they fall in all
types of categories.
There's time and
chronological data,
what year they were published.
There's categorical data, what
cities they were published in.
There's binary data, right?
Yes or no, simple
thumbs up, thumbs down.
Is there alum, is
there not alum?
And then there's numerical
data, pH and fold data,
which can span any
range of numbers.
And so while William Barrow
had all sorts of, you know,
interesting methods and
techniques and technicians
and secretaries working for him,
what he didn't have
was a desktop computer.
And so now we can look at
these correlations again
and the first thing you can
do, once we digitized all this,
is plot out all of the raw
data, the entirety of it.
And it's not as pretty as
perhaps it once looked.
There's a lot of scatter.
There's a lot of outliers.
And that's not unexpected.
These are real books with
unknown histories from all
over the place, and who
knows where they were
at what point in time.
But it just goes to show
how messy it can be.
One thing I've done is started
manipulating it a little bit
to see if there's anything
else you can learn.
So let's move away
from the big scatter.
These are some box plots.
I know box plots probably
something you haven't thought
about since high school.
Honestly, not really
something I've thought
about since high school.
But they do give you a
statistical snapshot by decade,
instead of Barrow's plots,
which were just median
values by decade.
You pick the median value.
And it gives you
nice clean plots.
This gives you some more
data on what's going
on in the distributions
over time.
For example, if you've
got a keen eye,
and the projector's colors
are behaving themselves,
you can see that the
data is right skewed.
What that means is
that the average value
for a decade is higher than
the median value for a decade.
You've got a couple of odd,
high-end outliers usually,
for each decade, that pulled
data toward the right.
Most of the lower
performing book.
There are more lower
performing books
than there are higher
performing ones,
pretty much across
the board by decade.
And you can do this for
any of the any of the data.
For the fold data by year,
for the tear resistance,
for the chemical properties.
And so what that does
and what I like doing
when I do this analysis is
it takes the original data,
what Barrow was looking at--
he had this original data,
we have this original data, we
start with the same numbers.
He's going just taking
the median values,
making nice cleanish plots.
And then we can take it and we
still get the same trend line.
You can see up to about 1700,
there's a pretty even plateau
in physical properties and
then it declines precipitously.
But you don't lose the data that
you lose in the representation
of data using just
median values.
You can also do some nice
heat mapping to start looking
at combined variables over time.
So these are now three variables
in one go, looking at year
and pH and how fold
endurance changes
over time with both of those.
Right? The hotter
values correspond
to higher fold endurance.
You can do the same
with tear resistance.
Both are physical measurements.
Right? You would expect
physical measurements,
the physical durability
of the books,
to kind of match each other.
And you can see in some
cases that's true, right?
In the 1650s to 1700s-ish,
that high pHs, so non-acidic.
That's true, they both match.
But then it's very easy to
reveal these odd little outliers
that I don't have
answers to yet,
about why there's a couple
books in here, in about 1850,
that are acidic that have
really high tear resistance
but don't have corresponding
fold endurance.
And so data manipulation
and representations
like this are something you
couldn't do in Barrow's day.
And they're something now
that we can start looking at
and figuring out
what's going on.
And so I'll jump back now to
the technical stuff I started
with at the beginning
about cellulose and size
and what's going on with
cellulose size in these samples.
The Barrow data has
macro-scale measurements.
What's happening at the physical
hand scale of brittleness?
It has all the way down to
chemical level information,
whether there's alum
present, whether the--
you know, what the acidity is,
which really is just a measure
of effective ion concentration.
But it's missing this
intermediary scale.
It's missing what's going
on at the size scale
of the cellulose molecules.
And so we come back to
micro-invasive testing.
That's why this collection
was so interesting to me
to use micro-testing on, is
that this is an actual book
collection, it has data on it.
It's something we might
be able to correlate
to actual collections objects,
and we can use now very small
minimally invasive sampling
to get another data point
on this interesting
book collection.
And so the first
thing that I did is--
so I've got data points
now on about a hundred
of these a thousand books.
Molecular weight
values of the cellulose
in about a hundred of the books.
And you can check that against
the original Barrow measurements
of acidity.
And you can see that
above neutral,
there's a lot of scatter.
But below neutral pH, in
acidic books, there's a decent,
pretty good correlation
between acidity and size
of your cellulose,
the molecular weight,
the DP of your cellulose.
And the first reaction on
seeing this plot is, well, duh.
[laughter] Right?
As it's more acidic, your
cellulose is going to break down
and you're going
to have smaller,
lower molecular weight
cellulose.
That's not terribly interesting.
But it is interesting that
this is a real world collection
of books.
These aren't lab scale papers.
These aren't things
that we've prepared
and artificially
aged in the lab.
It's a real world
collection of books.
It's unknown history.
We don't know if any given
book in a collection sat
in grandma's attic
for a hundred years.
It's unknown geography.
It may have been
printed in Italy,
but did it then spend
the rest of its life
in Sweden before it found
its way to the collection?
We don't know what
the housing was like,
we don't know the composition.
There's sizing all
over the place.
And we can draw essentially
a fairly universal trend line
between acidity and
molecular weight
in actual book collection
objects.
That's a powerful method.
And so how do they correlate
to physical properties?
These are color-coded.
It may be hard to
tell by decade.
And so you can see, as the
books get newer, less aged,
they actually are
in worse condition.
That's not a surprise
to any of us.
Books from the 18--
middle to late 1800s are
in worse condition
than the older ones.
The physical condition is lower.
The molecular weights are lower.
The cellulose size is lower.
But a lot of Barrow's
data used pH as one
of the primary indicators
of paper condition,
arguing that if you know
pH, if you can control pH,
if you can measure
pH and acidity,
you can predict what
the physical condition
of a book might be like.
And what we can do is we
can say in this regime,
before you start seeing a lot
of scatter at the high end,
that the molecular weight,
the DP, actually correlates
to physical properties closer
than the best predictors
that Barrow had at the time.
So there's some physical
meaning here to the size
of the cellulose and what the
physical condition is of a book.
And that's really seemingly a
powerful tool to use, you know,
about one millimeter diameter
of a sample to be able
to tell you something about
the quantifiable condition
of a piece of paper without
having to take that half a page
of an 8 1/2 by 11 sheet.
There's also this question
of what's been going
on in the last 50 years.
So this is Riley Thomas.
She was working with me
as a junior fellow
this summer looking
at both molecular
weight measurements.
She was responsible for some of
those data points that you saw
in the last couple plots.
But also looking at the dynamic
changing over time, right?
The Barrow data is nice.
You can say what happened
to a book 300 years ago,
but it is a snapshot
at this moment in time.
It doesn't answer the question
of what's happening
dynamically with the books.
How are any of those
properties changing
over natural aging conditions?
And so what Riley measured
was acidity and compared it
to Barrow's measurement for
acidity of the same books.
And so what I'm showing here is
just Barrow's lab's measurements
of acidity, the recently
measured acidity.
If we measured the exact
same values as Barrow,
they would fall on
this straight line.
And we see that at low
end, that's kind of true.
At the high end,
that's kind of true.
But in the middle, they tend
to start deviating consistently
lower than you would expect.
And we, again, don't
have a good answer why.
I have a couple of ideas.
Maybe there's enough
buffer alkaline reserve
in the non-acidic books that
it prevents any significant pH
changes over time.
Maybe these acidic ones
have kind of bottomed
out at the most acidic
values that they'll get to.
And it's the neutral ones that
you expect to change over time.
Just a thought.
We don't have any
proof of that yet.
Also looked at physical
testing data.
Same scheme here.
This is a lot more concerning.
The physical condition,
here measuring by fold data.
If we would expect everything
to fall in the same line,
that's not what we get.
In fact, everything
is a lot lower.
The condition of the books
physically is changing a lot
more rapidly for the worse than
the chemical properties are.
That's just a zoom-in of
that really clustered region
down at the bottom.
And so there's this question
of the physical properties
changing,
seemingly to change very fast.
The chemical properties,
in terms of acidity,
perhaps are changing a
little bit more slowly.
And so what's going on?
And this is something that size
exclusion chromatography might
be able to shed some insight to.
This is what I've started
doing some work on now.
This is stepping aside
from Barrow for a second,
talking about artificial
aging of book paper.
You can see that even
after just one day,
that's that green arrow
there, there's a drop
in physical properties.
And that's something
we can measure
by size exclusion
chromatography.
You can see changes in the
distribution of cellulose size,
even after just one
day of aging.
These higher molecular weight
components are starting
to go away.
They're starting to be replaced
by smaller molecular
weight components you expect
from chain scissions.
Overall molecule weight
averages start going down.
And you can see that, even just
one day of artificial aging.
And so if you look at these,
what's a little bit deceptive
in these plots is it
doesn't tell you anything
about the individual books.
You lose sight a little bit
of which book is connected
to which data point.
And so I've pulled out two here,
pointing to them, red and blue.
So the blue one is from 1664.
The red one is from 1745.
These were their pH values, the
old one, the new one, for both.
And so these were books, one
that was non-acidic in nature,
one that was about neutral.
You can see there's
a dramatic reduction
in the fold endurance
of the neutral book.
There's an even more
dramatic change, not in terms
of raw number, but in terms
of overall fold strength.
You're losing almost-- you
know, almost, you know,
down to ten percent of your
original fold strength.
This one, not quite as much.
And can you tell anything
in the molecule weight
distributions of those books?
And what's perhaps
interesting here is this book,
the one in red, the one
from 1745 that showed
that big overall reduction
in fold endurance starts
to show a tiny shoulder showing
up in the lower molecule
weight region.
What you would expect
to see from the result
of the beginnings of chain
scission, perhaps showing
that there are really
detrimental effects
on physical properties with even
just this really small amount
of smaller molecular weight
cellulose starting to form,
that you may not be able to
see from pH measurements alone.
Right? This pH change, whether
you go from 7 to about 7 1/2,
whether your measure is
effectively unchanged
and shows you that this
book is not acidic at all.
Doesn't quite match up with
the physical properties
you're seeing.
Whereas these changes
in the size
of the cellulose is something
that does start correlative.
Now, that's something that I've
found in general to be true,
that the books with
low fold endurance,
with low physical properties,
start having these really subtle
but indicative shoulders appear
in the lower molecular weight
regions of the cellulose.
Now, you can see
something is happening
that perhaps is not revealed
in other measurement
techniques that have been used.
And so technical conclusions.
I hope I've showed you
that micro-sampling
by size exclusion
chromatography,
just one millimeter of sample,
something that I've been
developing and starting
to use now on the
Barrow collection
to show how it might be used in
real books, can be useful either
in addition to other measurement
techniques or as a replacement
for other highly
invasive techniques.
It reveals some new insights
into the chemical mechanisms
of degradation that you
may have been misled
by measuring other
physical measurements alone.
Having that Barrow
data is also nice.
It gives us additional
statistical analysis
and correlations that
haven't been done before.
They're things that
we can build on.
There are things that we
can keep investigating,
looking at that dynamic
age based tracking, right?
And so thinking about
dynamic age based tracking
and what's changed over
the course of 50 years.
I want to talk-- I want
to take the last minute
to talk a little bit of my
thoughts just in general
on the Barrow Labs, and
hopefully you'll indulge me
in getting a little bit
philosophical for a moment
to discuss what I've
taken away from working
with the Barrow Labs
collections.
I've been really glad to be able
to work with such an esoteric
and unique collection.
And the thing I'm most impressed
by when I look at Barrow's work,
when I add to Barrow's work, is
not necessarily their insight
or even their outreach
in promoting what the
chemistry is of book paper.
The thing I'm most impressed
by, by the Barrow Labs
and the collections that
we have is their notes
and their diligence.
Right? Leave it to a
lab that's conserved--
that's concerned
with paper permanence
to find a permanent home for
these objects and these data
in a naturally aged collection
spanning half a millennium.
It shows, to me, and
really highlights to me
and has stressed the
importance to me, the importance
of technical notebooks
and technical note keeping
and keeping track of everything
that you've done, particularly
for people who are
concerned with preservation
over the natural lifetimes
of materials, right?
I hope that my notes
are as useful someday
as Barrow's notes, even
if it's in regret, right?
[laughter] If, God forbid,
I do something that's
regretted later on,
hopefully no one should go
back and look on any of my work
and say, what the
hell was he thinking?
[laughter] And should
know what I did
so that they can go
back and change it.
And so it strikes me
as especially true
when discussing natural
aging, right?
It's the nature of the job
as preservation researchers.
Odds are good that none
of us will see the results
of our labor, for
good or for bad.
Right? It's the nature of
long-term preservation.
It's the nature of working with
materials where our goal is
to have them outlive us.
Right? We could mess
it up badly.
But I hope everyone else is
inspired here to let no one
to be able to say, what the
hell where they thinking?
[ Laughter ]
So I'd like to thank a lot
of interns who have worked
on this collection, a lot of
staff in PRTD who've worked
on this collection over the
years, making it look nice
and pretty and archivally
housed and digitized,
which was a tremendous effort.
As Fenella mentioned
in the very brief bio,
I do not have a conservation
or preservation background
before I came here,
so I'm especially thankful-- I'm
thankful to all the PRTD staff.
I'm especially thankful to
Cindy and Lynn and Amanda,
who have helped kind of guide
me into the conservation
and preservation
world a little bit.
There are a couple references
that have helped
me along the way
that I've referenced
pretty heavily.
Sally Roggia, for example.
But I'd be happy to
take any questions
or comments if you have them.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Fenella France: So
we'll open for questions
and for the benefit of
our-- external viewers,
I'm going to ask Andrew
to rephrase the question
so that they can hear it.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Hi. This might be a bit
too complex to get into,
but I'm just curious how you
isolate or purify cellulose
from paper, which has obviously
tons of other stuff in it.
And then how you, from that,
are able to make sure you--
you know, you don't select
for non-degraded [inaudible]
incorporating artifacts.
>> Andrew Davis: Yep,
and that's a concern.
And I didn't dive
too deep into it.
So-- sorry.
The question for online
is how we make sure
that we isolate the cellulose
from the paper and make sure
that we're not introducing
other artifacts
by selectively removing parts of
it or not removing parts of it.
And I would say that a lot
of the work has been
done before me.
That's the hard work
that had been gone
on in fundamental labs.
And that's what I was talking
about in this sample preparation
that's fairly non-trivial.
It involves a lot of
solvent exchange steps,
including warm water,
including ethanol,
including dimethylacetamide, and
that removes some of the inks.
It removes the sizing, if
there's gelatin sizing,
if there's any kind of
large-- also large polymers,
protein-type materials
that are in there.
There's all of these insoluble
components, too, right?
Fillers and lignin.
Lignin, especially
in wood pulp paper,
very large scale, big molecules.
Those get separated out by
centrification and filtration.
We use very fine mesh filters.
And the crux of it is
this solvent system,
this lithium chloride
dimethylacetamide
solvent system.
And there's been some really
fundamental work on the physics
of that using light
scattering to show
that it is a good solvent,
by which I mean cellulose,
up to 10 million molecular
weight dissolves well
in this solvent system.
And so if we know that
cellulose is well-dissolved,
if we know that we're removing
all these other fillers,
that's about the
best that we can do.
I can't say for sure that if
there's degraded, you know,
lignin, little bits of
lignin that have broken off
that skew the averages
one way or another.
If there's little
bits of gelatin sizing
that have degraded to
smaller molecular weight
that can survive and get
processed into solution,
that those aren't skewing the
results one way or another.
But it's about the best that
anyone has come up with so far.
>> Thanks.
>> Andrew Davis: Does
that answer your question?
>> Yes.
>> Andrew Davis: Okay.
>> You mentioned
something about a punchline.
Can you at least
give us clues as to
which journal you
might publish in
or what you might call
your article and/ or when?
[laughter] Because that
was quite a teaser.
>> Fenella France: So that can
be linked to the website and go
out as an ROC [inaudible]
next published.
So we can get that to you.
But there's also some great
work that he mentioned that--
you know, in collaboration
with conservation.
So yeah, we'll make
sure [inaudible].
>> This is Judy Biggs, I'm
the team lead on the project
that you're referring to and
the work [inaudible] working
on the publication at the moment
and deciding where it'll be.
So we'll keep you posted.
Andrew's work is the last
part of this that we're--
that was really kind of
fundamental to the project,
so we're just looking
forward to [inaudible].
>> Andrew Davis: Sorry.
For listeners online, we're
just discussing publication
and how results are going to
get disseminated over time.
But we'll be keeping
people abreast
who are interested in it.
>> Fenella France: Charles?
>> If you want to
use a molecular size
or molecular weight as a
measure of the quality of paper
and you're wanting to
evaluate degradation,
time of historical samples, how
much variability would there be
in molecular weight or size
of the original material used
to make paper, depending on
source, species, et cetera?
For instance, cotton
versus wood fiber?
>> Andrew Davis: Mm-hmm.
So the question was checking--
if you're measuring
the molecular weights
of naturally aged historic
samples, is there anything
that can be said for the
original molecular weights,
particularly as it
concerns, say, the sourcing
of the material or the
process, making the material,
wood pulp versus cotton.
I get you, right?
>> Yeah, how much variability is
there in the starting material?
>> Andrew Davis: That's
something that I've been working
on in the lab here using our
paper reference materials
in CLASS, Center for
the Library's Analytical
Scientific Samples.
We have various wood
pulp papers.
We have various standardized
papers.
We have rag papers.
We can go back to these papers
and look whether
they're rag papers,
whether they're wood pulp.
And so the question about
what's the variability
in them is something I
can't quite answer yet.
I don't know.
And we can't go back, obviously,
and measure where these
books started from.
So we don't know how they've
been changing over time.
But in terms of the papers
themselves, we can start
with our lab papers that
have been, you know,
historically prepared
or that are rag papers
or that are wood pulp papers
and subject them to
artificial aging.
>> So [inaudible] materials.
>> Andrew Davis: Right, right.
But we could start with--
we'd obviously measure the
molecular weight at the start.
And I don't have an answer yet.
There's no easy trend
to be drawn between--
>> When you go back and look at
cotton, do you see a difference
between Egyptian cotton
and some other species?
>> Andrew Davis: That
I have not done yet.
And that's a good question.
>> Fenella France: We had
one question from online.
Is there any one thing
that Barrow could
have done differently
that would have been more
informative in hindsight?
[inaudible]
>> Andrew Davis: Oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
>> Fenella France: Can you
try and remember anything--
[laughter] Can you
repeat [inaudible] Andrew?
>> Andrew Davis: So yeah.
So the question from online
was, was there anything
that Barrow's labs could have
done differently in hindsight
that would have been
more helpful?
I'd say they did a
pretty tremendous job.
That's much more data
than you expect to get
from most researchers.
That's dodging the question
a little bit, I know.
[laughter] I would say that
[pause] you know, some of the--
where different samples were
taken in different parts
of a book would perhaps have
been a little bit interesting.
We can go back and flip
through his books and see
where pages have been torn out,
but we don't know whether
those pages were used
for tear resistance in
the cross-print direction
or tear resistance in
the machine direction
or any of these things.
And so again, a plug for PRTD,
where we've got class D coming
up with meta-data, where we're
tracking which pages are removed
for which tests and what
data is connected to what.
I think that's-- that
would have been interesting
to have kept track of because we
do see some differences whether
you take a sample from, you
know, the bottom edge of a book
versus the middle of a book.
Or the middle of a page
versus the edge of a page.
There are some slight
differences.
If you take it from the front of
a book or the back of the book
or the middle of the book,
there's a little
bit of differences.
And how much those differences
come out in his data,
that would have been
interesting to know.
>> Fenella France: We have
one more question here.
How were the physical-- how
were the physical locations
of the samples within
each book selected?
[inaudible] material
edge or [inaudible].
And were you able to choose
similar locations [inaudible].
>> Andrew Davis: Yes.
So-- one thing we've been--
one thing Riley Thomas,
who was working here,
was also interested in is
where are we testing, right?
And so I'll use one
of her slides.
And this book was only--
not quite accidentally
chosen for this past week.
[laughter] Kind of timely
appropriate, it's the 1800s.
Study of the Sky, with a chapter
on the moon and eclipses.
But Riley was interested
in where you're sampling.
And so the first answer
to that question is,
I can say that we've
been consistent
with these molecule
weight measurements
against Barrow's data of picking
just away from the margins
and away from the text block,
towards the bottom of the page.
And every sample we've measured
so far using this method has--
from in a book has gone from
that spot, just for consistency,
from a randomly selected
page in the middle,
not close, to either end.
We do see differences,
depending on where you check.
And that's something that needs
a little bit of work to figure
out and a little bit of
work to systemize over time.
And that I, again, don't have a
terribly good explanation for.
But for now, consistency
within the Barrow book
collections is what we're
going for.
>> Fenella France: Any
more questions in house?
Well, thank you all for coming.
As you can see, this is
still a work in progress.
And maybe in a year
or two years,
we will do the next installment
and also the wonderful research
from conservation,
when that comes up.
So please if you could join
me in thanking Andrew again.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.